kim kardashian may have filed for
divorce from kanye west back in february
but a source tells et the grammy winner
is still trying to win back his
estranged wife we have to thank kim the
most for allowing me to come back while
the rapper briefly dated supermodel
irina shaikh following his split from
kim a source tells et that the 44 year
old rapper is spending more time with
the kkw beauty founder and their four
children north saint chicago and song
and that he wants her back quote kim and
kanye's relationship is in a much
healthier space they have been speaking
a lot more frequently and have been
spending more time together on their own
and as a family kanye is totally trying
to win kim back and she is considering
it but he still has a lot to prove to
her him and i have been best friends for
a really long time the source adds that
kim and kanye's relationship had to
start over in order for it to begin
again and there are still things he has
to work on in order for things to
progress
quote she definitely sees that he has
been making an effort but she also knows
that he can be a loose cannon at times
and she is concerned about that she is
worried that one day he might snap and
become mentally unstable again making it
an unhealthy environment for the kids
keep my spirit alive
[Music]
more
alive
anything
kanye's new album donda has been making
waves ever since it dropped and in his
song hurricane he seemingly hints at
cheating on
chew it here kim go i get too rich here
i go with a new chick and i know what
the truth is still playing out the two
kids it's a lot to digest when your life
always moving and according to et's
source kim does have concerns that he
might be unfaithful if they reconcile
quote she is however hopeful and knows
that he is currently on the right track
a part of them both want to have a happy
healthy and faithful partnership like
they once had i always believe and trust
in him that he will eventually explain
himself because i know his heart
meanwhile a source says kim has been
leaning on her mom kris jenner her
sisters and a few select friends in her
immediate circle for support we are so
blessed to have the best support system
and the best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
kim's main focus is on her kids and she
wants them to thrive individually lead
happy and healthy lives and feel
supported and loved by their family the
source adds that the kids are in a great
space and hopeful that their dad can be
healthy and more involved in their
everyday lives again and no matter what
their relationship status may be it's
pretty clear kim and kanye are keeping
it friendly she supported him at his
listening parties for donda and even
participated in the final one where she
rocked a bridal gown and recreated their
nuptials
he's done miracles on me
he's done miracles on me
and kanye he's still there to support
kim too
on monday kim rocked this custom
balenciaga look to the met gala and a
source told et that the musician was the
one who influenced her look giving him
the courage to push creative boundaries
[Music]
you